I'm completely convinced that this daily
new series yeah is going to be the most
important thing in my life in a year I
[Music]
think it will be been fine because I
think the service market I think
hundreds of thousands of people a day
I'm going to watch it by the end of this
decide this time next year and if I'm
going to have three four or five hundred
thousand people watching it a day yeah
it's going to be the current there again
what do you did we never really done it
but what do you think cuz I have my
theories about it what do you think the
appeal is the daily fun I think
ultimately very honestly I think I think
selfishly for a very small group of
people in the world aspiring or current
entrepreneurs or business enthusiasts
that I'm interesting in that game right
and really I think that's what they deal
that like people who blown away by how
far by actions like usually I don't know
how people going to go if you don't
leave to comment on episode to vary
there were people that basically said
things like I've been watching you for
three years here with you for three
years I didn't get how hard you actually
work up here
joy six wonder I think I'm living a life
that I've done anomaly right I I think
that I wish I documented all my teeth to
this level because all the people that
think I was smart about Twitter they
don't even know how much
and I think this will do that easier
that we're capturing my conversation
about snapchat right now and in 18
months with that savvy literally the
only other main platform in the world
Island and biggest big yet
I'll have this narrative on how right I
was on a mainstream ability while so
many people all still think that it's
for kids or dicta right foot up snapchat
would love for you to go check out my
Instagram story I'd love to get your two
cents on it it's a grim story silk seems
the same [ __ ] that loved Instagram 11
months ago I'm like snapchat is [ __ ]
are literally going to say Instagram
stories or [ __ ] snapchat the best
hate that changed Iraq they hate that
change I love that change because it's
inevitable anybody that thinks that this
is going to kill snapchat is completely
out of their mind that's an incredibly
no chance statement and I would also say
that uh let's not forget that instagrams
already had success I think I said this
in the video with fast following vine
and doing video and that pretty much
killed mine there's no shot of killing
snapchat but I do think there's a shot
for people that have been able to build
big audiences on Instagram and have not
yet built big audiences on snapchat this
may create a scenario where they won't
try to create big audiences on snapchat
and that alone is a win for Instagram it
won't kill snapchat as snapchats too big
that's all it is too big too much too
many people have too many audiences
there's so many people that use it
plus there's a lot of people that won't
get it Instagram a shot here because
they think it's a copycat play and out
of the emotion that was I go to screw
that what snapchat taught us is there's
a place for context that is not that
serious
I think Instagram became like a museum
and snapchat became like your
conversations and I think that what this
is going to do for a lot of Instagram
celebrities content producers media
companies brands is allow them to
produce a lot more
for snapchat there's a lot of people on
snapchat that are way too fancy and only
post one or two things and they have to
be perfect this is going to give them
that ability to not be as perfect which
will make them create more all these
things start off as something it can
have any niche that the next big social
network is going to start out with some
niche some feature build critical mass
and then just become a content platform
with every option of every way to do it
got it eventually snackable content
evergreen content and live content will
be the cost of entry to be a modern day
massive social network
boom buddy under 25 for them more
specifically under 21 still favors it
and if I go right now
to the App Store which I had I didn't do
this morning which is unusual but if I
go right now and I'm just going to look
at the top of the charts and here they
are snapchat is number 4 it's not like
it's number 54 it's not dying like this
thought of deleting a platform that
hundreds of millions of people use that
could start different features in the
same way that Instagram didn't have
those features and everybody was going
to snapchat
yeah and why couldn't snapchat create
something tomorrow that changes the
outcome it makes zero sense in a world
where your job and your life is
predicated on you arbitrage and
attention and awareness to the things
you do to close a channel that isn't
charging you because it seems similar to
another channel would be the same thing
as saying you're not going to air it on
CNBC and Fox Business because they're
both CNBC and Fox Business or MSNBC and
CM if MSNBC and CNN both wanted you to
do a five-minute spot talk about the
same exact thing intuitively I feel like
you would do them both the only thing
that matters is attention that's what
you're trading on the only thing that
matters is other people's attention
because without it it doesn't matter
what you're creating right yeah
that's why you don't delete snapchat
that's why you get good at things that's
why Alexa play my daily briefs
here's your Flash briefing from Gary Vee
365 am i watching the patterns of
watching your two neighbors who that
exist Alexa stop that exists because I
know that's the next landscape of
attention let's talk a minute this is
run a sort of that workout
how did how is yours team but you may
comment if you like a few episodes ago
or some time ago stained or maybe no
reserves e3 said that your when you look
back at how you were 28 or third you and
you realize that you will come home and
goof off and you can't imagine living
like that anymore which is not anything
like really cabinet is like in what
happened
I have epiphany that I was including the
major that was going to allow
[Music]
the ambitions I actually actively
building no porno I actually decided to
care about technologies for selling in
the web YouTube and Twitter and map them
created the opportunity every minute of
every day for please like comment or -
will copy where's that one in the case
of my mom in my life I was I built
something but I wasn't easy with to do
you think that you have that others
don't have
kind of productive having that kind of
board
I would like wine ambition
the courses run for the process to
cancel our communal our breaker because
I still get to climb for the wing
loving the process I think that people
are going to watch concerts that I could
be pleased ten thousand dollars ahead
course in a mastermind course time
25,000 people in watch right
more time this year it's going to allow
me to give away other than ruin this
amount of freedom part whereas I could
not do this
yes charge every delivery people of
tomorrow I announce I am no longer
putting up contest I am creating the
Gary Vaynerchuk school mastermind of
marketing and it is five thousand
dollars a month so it's get them what
you've been getting do you know how much
money I would make tens a million
dollars
[Music]
because I have this equal ambition to
succeed I think I have enough talent to
do both that's why you're talking about
when we kind of leave on the table
that's a black-and-white example here I
know but nobody is giving the high
quality bison on giving away for free in
the world I believe that the truth and
if it's not true I strive for right but
if you work hard you think that it would
be a target or he thinks it is why I
mean
it's so hard to stay with you because
there's a whole notion of perceived
value and when you when you purchase
something you have a higher perception
of that value but I'm getting intense
value from watching you for free and I
wouldn't pay that money for it because
I'm not in that well it's because yes
and so that leads to watch Oprah Judy
shadow over you know Oprah these are all
very similar puzzles right
the answer is financially one will argue
that I bet I would make one would argue
a hundred thousand of you isn't going to
get me as much value as charging one
person five thousand dollars a month
right
what are you by $40 bucks yeah got it
so that's the book I truly believe what
I'm doing in my actions not my word is
proving my beliefs and how special I
really am and either I would be right or
I'll leave
[Music]
and I can talk about other ways that
you're leaving money on the table the
sports marketing
I still probably leaving a little money
is a legitimate reason at seventy-five
thousand trips here so a lot of stuff
that the deep-set don't hire me now
right
so I do think there's a lot of 15 year
olds like school and eventually will
care about me and
okay so the idea man I can ball and what
you do where you're away your kind of
gift like when you bite applause so hair
if your hair patient basically give it
away for 335 reviews on my time I get
four bodies yeah yes compared to in my
second year worth of content the create
that same why bother doing a video and
doesn't given anything to sort of write
it down sell it because I am NOT
romantic about housing and consumer
watching some I would hi
Gary Vaynerchuk would never leave Mary
we go yeah I might listen it to it Roger
right because of the way I can see I'm a
bad leader so I'm not in charge of doing
anything other than putting my positions
and I mean a feeling that you enjoy it
to avoid doing this
Michele yeah quite a bit to a point that
and you wouldn't enjoy it as much if
there were a bunch of rich this is five
five thousand dollars of money for it
you get through that small hours it
wouldn't be the same that's why he does
everybody except looks like me is doing
that yeah all right we're see your head
sit to the top look at that already and
I'm work yeah well I feel kind of calm
when I read some article like oh this
dude has this piece of insight that's
going to make you temporary though then
you get there and you sort of read it
and then obviously saying I'm the funny
thing is I think I could get away with
this and bring enough updating so much
value on my snapchat right now yeah I
mean snap kept secrets over the last
week for you
like more than people paying $10,000 a
month for a mirror on some Maxima
I'm doing it for free right and what's
interesting is even now you not paying
for it like you yeah so I don't care
it's an equity right
but the I'm doing is I'm conflicted
because like I just said I perceive it's
better because I'm not paying for it
because I feel a business or an hour of
authenticity device and genuineness hood
I don't get what now you make money on
it that's now you know why
businesspeople disrespect me logic I'm
doing all the right things yeah and
coming at my negative right detail
correct in my life yeah and a reporter
yeah and and and that's why I think that
I'll win war long term a long happy
there and that something should happen
because of it
right back up on ya what's the vibe that
you're getting here this week
I will I'm very insular okay to buy
business practices I won't go to this
place I don't know if people are near
time your tummy better for that later on
my friend and very the books from
anonymous my name's the askgaryvee show
the TV for daily view things on set with
what's going on what's going on with now
China it's about the wind attention
about the drought you you are you power
line Korsak you are 48 years old for sex
I also give you 48 years old are going
to consume us okay one why is it quiet
what just got going for us
the scale of 13 is 27 year olds that
will educate exclaiming six zeros to the
value prop over time okay yeah and then
the those kids will move on to something
else that's right not those things right
from the gentleman right right then
what do you think on the horizon so much
stuff here what do you think they'll
have arrived in that nobody is really
evolving obtain through PR they are the
artists it's a big kind of moving giant
I think
[Applause]
yeah yes
a big deal right like people think about
the internet you and I were sitting here
1979 and I perfectly predicted the
international scene yeah
I'm so fascinated by people's inability
to understand TRS I forget about your
imagine contact just a nationally not
right now in the head but that could be
a weird world it's the real world silky
happen yeah Castro but people don't play
in here sir
what the are gonna do for you what's
your interest in it I'm going to realize
when it's just about to go mainstream or
not yeah I'm going to whatever that is
my parcel and investment whatever my
vehicle for success sorry if I bought a
brand line marking it on there whatever
I left him right
[Music]